je pense que c'est plutôt sympa mais
voilà que je tombe bien cachés anti
cellulite et on va en parler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon petit disque est venu pour faire le
styliste en plus aujourd'hui
donc tu aimais pas du tout mon short 1
il est étalé partant des voix parce que
c'est quoi mon style quasi mon équipe et
s'amuse de l'être pas encore
[Applaudissements]
mais j'aurais dit maxime gainey mon
voisin de
wick et du soleil pourquoi n'êtes vous
pas sur scène ce qui fait de la magie
léviathan ce gars d'observer la
passerelle à tout moment il ya une
apparition vers la comprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah mais quelle star quelle star bruce et
sert de touche passe ambiance de feu les
zones isolées
ça les amuse et là bas aussi
et ma maman elle s'est vue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous invite à lever pour aller voir
[Musique]